Film Courage: So I know you had said in another
interview that Richard Avedon was one of your
idols [along with maybe] Francesco Scavullo,
all of these fashion photographers.
So it seems like that was your aim at that
time, either that or products?
Jay Silverman: Well, when I was going to photography
school you pick mentors if you are fortunate
enough to be motivated by them.
In my case I had Richard Avedon, I had Pete
Turner, and I had Scavullo, Annie Leibovitz.
You know these are people that I looked at
as someone I’d like to be like.
And when I finished school I moved to New
York and it became almost a surprise to me
when I realized that “I think I can make
a living in Los Angeles.
I don’t think I have to live in New York.”
And I knew back then that lifestyle was more
important to me than money.
I did not want to leave my family and my friends
so I came back to LA and set up a business
that way.
Film Courage: Especially the allure of doing
a VOGUE cover, especially when you are just
starting out.
Jay Silverman: Well it’s curious that you
say that because as a photographer at the
beginning of my creative career, I did everything.
I did fashion, I did product shots, everything
but a wedding.
And then you wake up one morning and somebody
gives you some advice, you know?
And that advice came at a high price.
I paid a lot of money for someone to give
me advice when I was in my 20’s on how to
go to the next level.
And the advice came with a question.
The question was very simplistically what
makes you different from everybody else and
he really screwed with me because he did not
want to tell me what the simplistic answer
was.
So I tried everything “Oh, I do great people
shots.
I build great sets.
I can motivate children.”
And then he said “No…no…no.
Think about it and get back to me next week.
And I was terrified.
I thought ‘how can I be so stupid?
He’s asking me a question about my own career?’
And then finally I spit out….“I’m a
problem solver!”
And the guy looks at me and I look at him
and says “Finally!”
And that really kind of encompasses everything
about creativity.
How do you make a documentary?
You’ve got to solve the problem.
How do you…in my case I came across a great
idea for a TV show called The Cleaner (based
on personal experiences) and how do you sell
it?
Well you wake up one morning and you sell
it.
You know, you’ve got to solve the problem.
In my case since I was half filmmaker/half
photographer I started videotaping the highlights
(the real highlights) that the show is about.
It was the first AMC drama that they made
(it was way before The Walking Dead and all
this other stuff).
And we were lucky enough to have Benjamin
Bratt as the star.
The character that he played on the TV show
was a gentleman that I knew in real life.
So I filmed him multiple times talking about
what he did for a living and condensed it
into a 60-second piece and that’s how I
sold the TV show.
And it wasn’t until 6 or 8 months later
that I’m working with a crew on a pilot
where they say “Do you know that this is
like one-in-a-million that you can sell a
show with no show of success?”
And that’s kind of how I’ve run my whole
career is trying to focus on my goal, what
is the real net choice that I’m going to
make.
Am I going to make a movie about the circus
or am I going to go out and make a movie about
somebody who goes out and saves people from
themselves.
And that’s kind of why I have a portfolio
visually of different styles.
I’m always interested in trying to grow.
Film Courage: Well speaking of growing…looking
back on that Mr. Miyagi or whoever he was
who was sort of mentoring you, do you ever
think about what would have happened if you
hadn’t met this person (as frustrating as
that experience was for a little bit)?
Jay Silverman: Well, this person defined…it’s
funny you can hire a psychologist to come
into your business, they are called business
consultants.
They come in, they try to read your mind,
they try to read what your goals are and they
try to help you understand how to get there
and the most basic thing is who are you?
What do you really offer?
And it’s funny because as you listen to
other filmmakers talk, listen to other writers
talk, it all comes down to one thing and that
is defining what your goals are.
And Bethany (who is my producer) brought me
the opportunity to go to a screenwriting fest
where producers and writers are able to meet
and actually get pitched.
On one level it’s a little bit like one
of those real life dating situations where
you have 3 minutes to meet somebody and the
bell goes off and they switch.
It’s a little bit like that but immediately
they are pitching you their movie.
And I said to Bethany “I don’t want to
take any pitches for science-fiction, I don’t
want to take any pitches for comedies, I don’t
want to take any pitches for…I want real
life stories.”
And it helped define my goal which is to find
something that I wanted to do rather than
be inundated by these various other forms
and I’m not critical of them it’s just
not what I want to do?